the Asian shame is so crazy Asian shame
is yeah when it's exposed to the rest
like the perception is more important
than what is really going and other
Asians can't figure it out except for
except for Bart
[Music]
so there's a comedian who's who told the
joke so bad that an entire country was
offended by it and has asked Interpol to
trace her location Interpol what could
the joke be that is so bad and what
could the country be that was so
offended what do you guys think she's
buying Dubai or something I think it's
got to be one has to be an Islamic
country really but it's Interpol though
would an Islamic country ask the UK
government to help oh Interpol UK yeah I
thought it was International
jurisdiction this because it's inter oh
the [__] interval is dude oh
International police that's what I
thought but I thought the headquarters
is you I don't know just say that then I
gotta shorten it up what kind of joke
could be so bad for let's start with
there what's the joke like bacon or
something
I don't know related content yeah what's
an example of a joke yeah I would
imagine it would be something like
religious like yeah I think that is a
definite spot where I'd be like yeah
right you got to be careful with that
um I I actually don't think it's an
offensive joke I think it's so it's a
dumb joke and it's so stupid that it's
offensive and people got offended
because it was just bad okay like it
doesn't even hurt anyone's feelings it's
just you can't you're not a good
comedian okay yeah like your mom's fat
like a pork That's funny though it's
like a yo mama joke
yeah
joke in a comedy show and everyone was
like what yo what the [__] how dare you
this [__] some people don't have doors
what uh what country do you think would
be that offended Saudi Arabia I don't
know Japan
in Japan okay interesting all right
here's a hint
the comedian is Asian the joke is Asian
the country is Asian
North Korea that was my first initial
thought of my head yeah no it's not
North Korea all of you would think it is
though well all right a lot of okay
there are eight I mean there are Asians
with no sense of humor they're usually
next shark commenters yes thank you but
damn man but Vietnamese Filipino are
laid-backs I already take them how about
Taiwanese they're hilarious they already
laid back up did you see did you see
there was a Filipino thing recently
where uh there was this like infographic
that showed who are the most racist
countries in the world Philippines got
number five and then and then all the
comments from the Philippines were like
yeah Filipino
that's what I mean
Filipinos Vietnamese and Thai are like
the most laid-back people when it comes
to humor like no no way they're like
Filipinos coming up is it China
it's not China which is interesting yeah
Singapore Korea almost Singapore oh
Malaysia Malaysia Malaysia was it Jason
Cheney in Malaysia so Malaysia got
offended what would offend Malaysia
Muslim not Muslim it's not Muslim it's
not Muslim oh you [__] made fun of
their Nasi Lemak dude
they're like you made fun Amigo ring can
we get that for lunch
that might be worse that might be worse
but no Malay um Malaysia got offended by
a joke actually here's the joke and
here's a comedian okay
okay serious Cheney isn't it Jason Jenny
right there it's not Jason Jenny it's
close it's Josh lynchia
Malaysia Singapore
Malaysia okay yeah
this isn't it yeah
she's Singaporean
sometimes he cry because he thought
We're not gonna survive without you but
then four years later we became a first
world country and you guys Malaysia what
are you now still a developing country
oh that's [__] Wild
it's too funny yeah Malaysia
I feel the hate
y'all trying to come around like in
Singapore you're looking good
why haven't you visited me 40 years yeah
I I tried but you know my airplanes
cannot fly
oh
it's going missing not funny
[Laughter]
some jokes don't last yeah that's good
she got the Singaporean [__] twang
you know so that is it about the
airlines she's Singaporean but she's I
think she's born in America oh is it
about the airlines because I feel like
it's a joke about the airline that went
missing Asian morality it's not really
like
if we actually [__] up it's how other
people perceived if we [__] up it
I don't really care but if my friends
found out he got a B then I'm like what
the beat the [__] out of me right right
that's a good point yeah it is excellent
if Malaysia's Airline like oh you your
Airlines get lost dude they're like oh
[__] so much shame I can't take this
yeah oh see that makes us all crazy it
wasn't the third world country that
pissed them off out of all of the
comments that I've read about this
nobody said that that's pretty
interesting that's I think that's very
smart because Asian shame is so crazy
Asian Sheamus yeah when it's exposed to
the rest like the perception is more
important than what is really good and
other Asians can't figure it out except
for Bart
because everybody's focused right now on
the disrespect to like uh Malaysian
Airlines but then she's pointed out too
she's like people in America make 9 11
jokes like crazy like crazy so what what
are what are people pissed about can we
ask the Singaporean like what the
context Is Here Yeah I have no idea dude
is there beef between because the
history of it is
um they used to be a part of Malaysia
until they had a Uprising and they
separated so is there like some kind of
animosity there or like something I
don't get that's quite exactly what she
said in a lot of ways like you know I'm
sure it's a little so she's she's told
that joke many times it's a joke it's
only now getting backlash because it's
now like making its rounds and on the
internet everywhere but she's told it in
Singapore it kills she's told it in lots
of places like
um but now like you know Malaysians are
seeing it and they don't like and now I
didn't think about what you said now
they don't like it well they got
different laws man when we went out
there
um
we did some radio interviews and then
one of them asked um they're like so um
you know how do you think about like
University or your college experience
and they were just like oh not everyone
needs it and then they're like can we
cut that really quick
um can you not say like don't I'm like
don't [__] ask me a question that you
don't want an answer to but we're so
used to like just being in America and
like speaking yeah they're like don't
freak you guys forgot we don't have free
speech over here so yeah
okay fair enough so they can't they have
a different I think set of laws and
morality when it comes to what to say
right because that's hilarious like and
you would never think in the states to
call the cops because someone offended
you
verbally like it's not a threat it's not
against the law so they're asking
Interpol to like identify our location
so they can like apprehend her yeah and
then [__] like bring her in for
questioning and trial like a like like
an absolute criminal yeah they I think
they're trying they're trying to figure
figure out how to like how to get in
trouble it there were over a hundred
protesters at the American Embassy
asking in Malaysia trying to demand that
she be banned from entering Malaysia
extradite her extradite her yeah
different set of rules man that's
exactly what that is yeah interesting
the interesting thing is why I showed so
much of it is that what's making the
rounds is just the tiny little part
where she talks about the Malaysian
Airlines and it kind of it is like she's
also saying yeah it's not fair that the
little clip is getting you know uh when
you do watch the whole thing from the
beginning where she's talking about the
Malaysia Singapore and like as in like
from her perspective of being
Singaporean it does have more contact
and does make more sense I can still
understand why people would be so mad
about you know the fact that like oh
like 200 some people lost their lives in
this thing but it's like
but also the rules of like American
because she's at the comedy seller no is
that where that video possibly yeah but
yeah yeah she's in New York I think
she's not even in Malaysia yeah so it's
also too like I think the rules of
American Comedy like go over the heads
of like Americans sure yeah you know
what I mean so it's like once you
once you go outside the country it's
just like it's just really hard to gauge
what the responses are going to be or
how people are going to take it right
because they assume that you're just
saying how exactly how you feel rather
than like I'm trying to say something
kind of shocking but have a funny thing
you're crappy yeah it's like that that
concept of Comedy a stand-up comedy
specifically I think is lost on most
people even in America bro you know how
sometimes people say like if people get
offended by a joke it just wasn't a good
enough joke do you think this was a good
enough joke to have like earned yeah I
thought it was a good job that's a great
joke but also too it's like the word
play at the end was clever yeah some
jokes don't land I thought saved it yeah
she's like hey hey some jokes don't land
it's comedy yeah exactly just Let It Go
I mean
yeah we're no strangers to saying [__]
that people get pissed off
this audience is a little different here
yeah like something I'll catch myself
outside of here like cracking a joke
that I'm like trying to be like very
over the top about but then people are
like whoa you really think that and I'm
like no I don't really think that like
I'm just saying that just to like yeah
and then tip has to apologize on your
behalf yeah or just does that just bro
random people stop playing with them
clients mostly
no just other stupid jokes you're right
though even within America we're losing
that understanding of satire context and
like everything everybody takes
everything's so seriously that's the
real pandemic everyone got Asperger's
and [__] yeah that's what that's what
aliens don't want to be here yeah yeah
they're like I thought you were gonna be
funny
you know like because you know how they
get [__] late out there because there's
the satellite like transmits kind of far
yeah so then they're like watching 90s
jokes and then they're like on a road
trip how excited they're like I can't
wait to meet Chris Rock
if we're Finn here I come
it's super nice
yeah I again there's like such an
ongoing hatred for this comedian like
it's pretty heavy it's pretty heavy
um countries like Malaysia involved and
they're calling Interpol they're taking
us see they're really taking it Mega
series and again I understand how they
feel but also there's a ton of 911 jokes
out there bro like yeah stuff gets joked
about no matter what it is it will get
joked about and in some ways it's a form
of healing it's a form of coping and
humor is kind of the best approach for a
lot of these times I think it's 100 a
form of healing and then if you're still
sensitive about it you should probably
not breathe for a long time
but you really think the inner pole is
good for you
yes that's what she said she
screenshotted like she reposted on her
Twitter the uh the Interpol like request
thing and she goes I would love to see
the face of the agent that got this
freaking
she's really like owning up to like
she's not
she's not yeah she seems kind of like
yeah like she's very if she makes it
through this I feel like she has a
pretty freaking dude I think she will
she probably will she'll be okay she'll
make a joke about the situation yeah she
should then he said this is they brought
it back from the past well no she's been
doing this joke for a long time only now
has it received this kind of backlash
because it it just hit the viral you
know algorithm and it just showed all
the wrong people that weren't in this
club that weren't prepared to hear
comedy that don't want to hear a joke
that don't even want to even think about
the Malaysian flight anymore you know so
understand that I was wearing them
messed up It's Gonna Hurt who it's meant
to hurt yeah but everybody gets [__]
mad about everything on the internet
dude as soon as something goes viral as
soon as a guy saves somebody on the
highway I'm sure people in the comments
like what a [__] piece of [__] I
can't believe you did that like people
get mad over [__] everything and so
many things are clipped out of context
too like almost everything nowadays is
clipped out of context right I mean I
just recently was watching a pottery
making video in a tutorial and there was
a raging [__] argument in the
comments section yeah for pottery for
pottery it's over bro
so it's not just next shark yeah that's
it dude aliens come get us end the game
yeah
also the outrage the outrage was on next
shark by the way
[Music]